اما مسؤول السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل فقال ان دعم
اوكرانيا سيظل على راس نقاشات الدول
الاعضاء بما في ذلك كيفيه زياده مستوى
الدعم العسكري
من التمويل
في المانيا كان هناك كثير من التعهدات
بالدعم الذي سيتم تقديمه وهذا سيكون بحضور
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
وقال وزير الخارجيه الروسيس الجيلا برو
فان الحرب بين الغرب وروسيا لم تعد هجينه
على حد تعبيره بل باتت شبه حقيقيه
خلال اجتماع مع نظراته الجنوب افريقيه
خلال زيارته لبريتوريا واضاف لابروف ان
بلاده ليست ضد الوساطه بشان اوكرانيا
ولكنها كلاب ليست مهتمه بالمفاوضات بدافع
من الغرب على حد وصفه قال انه كلما طال
امد الازمه الاوكرانيه زادت صعوبه الوصول
الى حل لها
نقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفينا من فينا فارمر
باسلوبند وزير الدفاع النمساوي السابق
ومدير المعهد المساويه السياسه الاوروبيه
والامن ومن موسكو الينا سبونينا الكاتبه
والمحلله السياسيه اهلا بكما ابدا معك
سيده الينا سبونينا اذا هذا الكلام
الاوروبيه الان عن حزمه عاشره من العقوبات
ضد روسيا قد تكون قادمه في المرحله
المقبله وحديث ايضا عن مصادره الاصول
الروسيه لاعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
نهاركم سعيد نعم كل هذا هو مقلق تشديد
العقوبات وايضا
وعود جديده من قبل دول الغرب بالنسبه
لامدادات الاسلحه الجديده وهي ممكن ان
تختلف نوعيا من امدادات السابق
بهذا السبب نحن نرونا انه القوات الروسيه
تحاول ان تتقدم اكثر واكثر في الشرق وجنوب
شرق اوكرانيا فهذا ما ممكن ان تفعله روسيا
اولا همم تعتمد على قواتها ولا تراهن على
امور سياسيه والتحالفات سياسيه ولكن ثانيا
وزياره وزير الاوقاف تشير الى ذلك روسيا
تحاول ان تضبط هي تنجح بعد الاحيان في هذا
الشيء انها غير منزله وانه نزلت روسي
مستحيل والان وفي ظهور جنوب افريقيا وكل
هذه البلدان روسيا والصين وجنوب افريقيا
وغيرها هي اعضاء في منظمه بريكس ومنظم
بدعه تيام راينا مناورات عسكريه ما بين
روسيا والصين على الشواطئ جنوب افريقيا
بتنسيق مع حكومه هذه الدوله ماضيه اذا في
خطوطتها
موسكو كما تقولي السيده
عذرا كلما ذهب الاوربيون الى حزمه جديده
من العقوبات ضد روسيا تزيد موسكو في
الصعيدها على الارض في هذه الحرب على
اوكرانيا ما الذي ستحققه حزما اخرى عاشره
من العقوبات ضد موسكو
ماتش ماتش
الان نتحدث عن العقوبات بحديثاتها الان
ولكن انا نتحدث عن مؤشر واضح وصريح من
الدول الاوروبيه ضد اي اعتداء اضافي من
الجانب الروسي بالاضافه الى ذلك تبرز
المخاوف المرتبطه بسلامه وامني المحطات
النوويه وهو امر اساسي تناقش به الوزاره
الاصول الروسيه 300 مليار دولار
واستخدامها في اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا هل
يمكن لخطوه كهذه ان تحظه باجماع الاوروبي
اه دول تسكشن
[موسيقى]
تستمر وبعد القصف المتكرر والعنيف لعدد
كبير من المدن الاوكرانيه عدد متزايد من
الاوروبيين يقول انه من الواضح ان على
روسيا ان تدفع ازاء الضرر الذي يلحق
بالبنات تحتيه الاوكرانيه
وجاء قصف في البنا التحتيه ليس فقط
العسكريه بالايضا المدنيه
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان الحرب مع الغرب
اصبحت شبه حقيقيه ما رسالته بهذا الكلام
هذه الرساله هي ايضا
مقلقه بالنسبه لمواطني روسيا ولكنها مغلقه
بالنسبه لموطنيه دول الغرب لانه نحن خطوه
بعد خطوه نقترب من خطر المواجهه المباشره
ما بين روسيا ومنظمه حلفنيته هذا ما يقصد
به وزير البروف نعم روسيا لا تريد ان تدخل
في هذه المواجهه وهذا براي ليس لصالح
روسيا ولكن همم اطاله هذه الازمه ايضا ليس
لصالح روسيا ولكنه قد حدث فاروس تريد ان
تظهر الان انه اذا ما وافق الدول الغرب
على فتره المفاوضات واذا استمرت في
تحريكانيا على اتخاذ هذه المواقف فهذا
يعني انه روسيا ستكون مستعد لكل
السيناريوهات بما فيها المواجهه مع منظمه
حلته
شكرا جزيلا لك الينا سبونينا الكاتبه
والمحلله السياسيه من موسكو شكرا
لمساويه سابق ومدير المعهد النمساوي
للسياسه الاوروبيه والامن شكرا لكما